las corridas de toros podrían
desaparecer en ciudad de mexico el
bastión de la tauromaquia en américa
latina' por primera vez el congreso
local votó para abolir esta práctica los
animales son sintientes y cuando
nos damos cuenta de eso cambia la óptica
los animales ya no son cosas los
animales son esos seres sintientes que
tienen derechos sin embargo los empleos
y el comercio que genera la llamada
fiesta brava han frenado hasta ahora la
prohibición según datos de la secretaría
de agricultura de méxico para el 2018 la
industria taurina movió 343 millones de
dólares generó 80.000 empleos directos
146 mil indirectos y movilizó a más de
50 mil espectadores ante las críticas
por el maltrato animal los toreros
aseguran que las corridas son el final
más digno para los toros
lo que te puedo decir desde mi punto de
vista es que todo todo el conjunto del
arte que es la tauromaquia tiene que
terminar de esa manera no el toro tiene
que tiene que terminar así gracias a
dios ese es un arte en el que yo también
estoy entregando mi vida no para que se
apruebe la eliminación de la tauromaquia
falta una votación en el pleno del
congreso local que aún no tiene fecha
hasta el momento en cuatro estados
mexicanos se prohíben las corridas de
toros y en otros siete son patrimonio
cultural mientras que en latinoamérica
aún son permitidas ampliamente en
paraguay perú y venezuela- parcialmente
en ecuador bolivia y colombia y
prohibidas en brasil uruguay chile y
argentina